[Music]
all right guys you know what we're
talking about what we're talking about
roller coaster someone died on it no no
we're not that dark here this is JK News
man everything's really light and every
roller coaster article we do someone
dies someone's head chops off this one
could be funnier it could be funnier or
what if's like a new cool ride new
technology yeah we don't do that
someone's writing on when's the last
time because the video might come out in
like 3 years when's the last time you
guys rode a roller coaster I think like
3 months ago maybe really I thought you
hate roller coasters was it tsunami
punani you you went with ta yeah it was
like a notb farm what's the one that
rotates around the Wrangler or oh I know
what you're talking about but but for
kids so I don't know that one no it's
it's an adult one because uh I thought
he was old enough I thought it was old
enough for him but then when he got on
and it spun around and you see his head
like this and he couldn't lift it
himself I was like oh [__] we should
have waited a year but he he met the
height requirement no he did I remember
he's just a big kid though no it's very
fun that stuff scared me away from
roller coasters as a kid I think I was
maybe Too Tall not thick enough and I
remember wiggling around in the seat
belts yeah that's that's scary cuz it's
like a ride within a ride now you're
like all right
I'm you guys you guys remember the
Gravitron or whatever at the
carnival do you ever think about the
first roller coaster before they knew so
it's like it's like hey how tall does a
kid have to be and they're like we don't
know yet even
got to get on why every year it's like I
like if your legs are too small the seat
won't hit you and you'll probably just
slip out probably weight vop yeah yeah
yeah some kind of ratio I I actually
don't love roller coasters but I do love
like theme parks yeah I like theme parks
I like them all yeah you're trying to
spin upside down and [__] puke what
theme park do you like that's the thrill
It's A Thrill Ride yeah I don't like
thrill rides I like theme parks oh well
that's the point though the thrill is
sometimes fun for people yeah no no no I
understand why you may enjoy I just
don't enjoy roller coasters at
Disneyland they're pretty mild that's
why I like Disney those aren't like
thrill R oh except for Guardians of the
Galaxy AK Tower of teror how about that
that Bops and so does uh you I don't
like it literally B you done the Avatar
one Space
Mountain is that the coolest [__] ever
you got to go to Shanghai and ride Tron
all right I'm down they just opened a
Tron in Orlando but yes I would love to
go to you don't have to go to Shang I
would love to Har pot [__] with the
dragons is [__] insane dude that one
sick that's Orlando in time dude best
thing ever Harry Potter's [__] rad
bro all right check this out though what
happens if you're on a roller coaster
right wait I can't see someone's dead I
got you I got I'll just watch his
reaction no no nobody's dying Wonderland
Lumberjack get
upside upside down 30 minutes more than
30 minutes right yeah is that even
possible your head's going to explode
there's some that have been hours before
while you're just upside down imagine
the momentum this thing just spins like
this right and then eventually for some
reason when it does get both of you guys
perfectly at the top how are people not
puking oh you just upside down the whole
time imagine the headache oh [__] you
got to have a headache your face is red
dude fall asleep don't won't that kill
you I feel like you would get knocked
out from all the blood pressure no can
anybody be how long can someone be
upside down great question how's there
not like an emergency ladder I don't
like that thaty goog H can it be upside
down for how's there not like a ladder
that you know that they're quick to
[__] they should they usually do yeah
Canada that's why oh it was Canada is
that a carnival cuz it looks more like a
carnival then it does look like a roller
coaster at a theme park yeah I also
won't do like Carnival smart yeah I need
some like steady carnivals if the roller
coaster has [__] inflatable Wheels
underneath I can tell they just built it
like 3 months ago I'm out cuz the roller
coasters at carnivals look just like a
foldout bench yeah those canopies they
which whipping it out and then as it's
going the whole thing is like this out
like no I'm good dude and you see the
ride operator the ride operator is like
a drunk fat dude or like a teen and
you're just like that they're [__]
controlling my life that's part of the
experience do people go to carnivals
frequently these days yes I say these
things but I ride all the rides I do too
so like the state fairs in Sacramento
remember not everybody has a means to go
to even not Berry Farm for sure for sure
Carnival is like the the thing that
especially at a kid house happiness
level they're not processing whether or
not this is like [__] Premier
Disneyland they're just like that's a
ride and they see a ride they're [__]
happy that's true one just popped up in
Vegas you should check it out which one
a petting zoit no Carnival oh petting
zoit petting zoit why isn't that's what
Vegas is missing like a legitimate theme
park yeah I feel like they could get one
Vegas is the theme park it is it's an
adult theme park bills bro they have oh
they reopen huh no you don't want you
don't want Vegas to have like a family
theme park yeah more kids coming out
there it's going to take away from what
Vegas is you just put it off the strip a
little bit Vegas all of Vegas is the
theme park and you have to go to
different hotels cuz then at the
Stratosphere you can ride that thingy
thing and then you can do
Gokarts you can do the shitty ass Ferris
wheel at the link or the link oh yeah
dude at Red Rock you can drop your
[__] kids off at that one place and
they'll watch your kids for you while
you go gamble and get [__] up it's
like a straight up like DZ Discovery
Zone built into the casino they
constructed the whole city
to extract money from middle class
families and let their kids just play
and Chinese people oh it's all Chinese
restaurant owners yeah that's the move
huh we tried to drop ta off and they
asked for immunization records I'm like
dude this place is legit I was like oh
[__] I guess you have to go back home
and get it or something dude my sister's
such a square she wouldn't let her kids
stay there and I'm like the kids first
of all think you're boring as [__] they
would have a better time the kids wanted
to cuz me and Gio didn't want to drop
them off Tao was like what's that that y
I'm like they see the the slides and the
crazy I want to go in for [__] me bro
he ask for immunization records I'm like
damn this place is crazy it's like when
you you ever build a a tree for cats and
they immediately start using it like
they know it's for them yeah Weir how
they know but yeah when kids see all
that [__] blue orange [__] they just
know it's for them well to be fair when
you build a [__] desk drawer for
yourself the cat will jump on top of it
true but there is something about dude
that tree Once you bust that tree out
they start fu
it feels good they love that's true when
you see like a pirate ship in a park or
when you see a treehouse as a kid you're
like what's that that's for me you're
like I want to play on that but at the
same time if you see a treehouse or a
pirate ship in a park even as an adult
you're like it does look I remember when
my Park had these half tunnels as a kid
just going into the tunnel was like
insane oh yeah parks are crazy now too
even Vegas especially but you drive
around some parks like what their slides
and [__] look like are not what m I had
like two slides maybe a tire slide dude
they got twisty twist slides got [__]
ropes got built-in zip lines Army ropes
D the bridges they got like a whole
Bridge yeah it's mini Disneyland [__]
with that spoiled ass Zoomers wait
what's a zomer what's right now what's
ta do you just like spend all your time
telling all the the younger Generations
that they're sof what is I feel like you
hit 30 and you just have to like let
them know Alphas I think they're Alpha
are betas yeah the next gen is supposed
to be Alpha then that's tight next kids
are about to be the best
T he's already off to the wrong track
then yeah call him the bees or something
nobody's calling them Zeta right now or
no that doesn't work is z is and Zeta
you know how Super Bowl they do Roman
numerals yeah yeah but for Super Bowl 50
it was going to be a big L so they're
like we can't have Super Bowl l so
they're like we'll do Super Bowl 50 for
this one you got to have like a
something else for beta it can't be n
make them beta dude yeah skip it go well
cuz every generation's getting weaker so
they might actually be the beta [__]
little [__] they'll like absorb it
and like it yeah they we're generation B
it reverse we're [__] or they have to
like flip it like b genen b Jen it
probably be B Jen you I mean that
doesn't sound so bad that sounds
actually better that's B what generates
huh what's the sple oh yeah the upside
down yeah I don't like rides like that
have you ever been stuck in a ride
upside down or like just stuck in a ride
at all stuck in the ride yeah but not
upside down which ride were you stuck
in [__] man I feel like get stuck all
the time like we I remember we were in
the [__] uh yeah haunted match always
you get stuck what like Disneyland yeah
Disneyland why do they keep breaking
It's a small world I was stuck in It's a
small world for like 30 minutes one time
you heard it's a you know how insane
that is that's bad man that's really bad
what did you do like this you're just
bumper to bumper on the [__] boats
and you're sitting there and it's in the
dark and then it's [__] s just water
too I'd rather be upside down I'd rather
be upside down nap did you do
this no that helps no one started
climbing out of the boats and getting
the [__] out of there yeah no because
it's deep water you'll drown they turn
the music off do you think they get a
twisted sense of satisfaction watching
you guys suffer in the dark like you are
working there [__] y got [__] night
vision goggles laughing you check how
long a human can be upside down before
they die it the first couple things is
don't do it for more than a couple
minutes but then after that it says if
you if you stay for over 24 hours you
could suffocate a couple minutes to 24
hours is a long David Blank could
probably do it for like a year I bet
some people get brain damag though I bet
some people get [__] up in July a
roller coaster ride got stuck upside
down for hours oh my God and then people
died no I don't think there's a lot of
death going on nowadays what's there's
got to be death everywhere and I think
they husher I heard Disneyland no I
heard Disneyland be people get their
head decapitated at the Astro mountains
K got ate by a crocodile dude oh yeah
remember that two months after that I'm
at that same Hotel oh [__] I saw the
little beat that's you see a crocodile
come up on the no no cuz then I heard
they went around just killed them all
yeah put that in the news Disney with
vengance
isad they're all dressed up goof coming
out with that kind of money Micky and
Minnie is like wooo and then [__]
goofy like go kill you [__] they it's
all in slowmo and they they got an
internal video about it they probably
filmed it yeah they probably filmed it
for staff sick Disney's kind of gangster
I think if you're going to do it you
might as well dress like one of the
mascots and do it yeah yeah for the Tik
Tok Buzz Light them all up that's got to
be a big deal for like [__] a death
to happen on Disney property they go so
extreme that even in Orlando they don't
have mosquito on their Parks no they're
we need Disney technology read this
whole article oh is it because like they
spray mist or some [__] we need Disney
technology basically the whole park is
almost Master engineered in a way that
there's no sitting water which is the
thing that attracts mosquitoes the most
and then so so maybe there's a spray
thing I heard something about that even
about the Anaheim one where there's like
not mosquitoes no flies
maybe they got citrella everywhere even
like don't they have like pet cats they
let out at night to kill something genus
they're everywhere so do do they have to
catch the cats in the morning they might
be robot cats they're probably like my
cats when I have a guest over and they
just go run hide they're always just
chilling you you'll be able to find one
they really are kind of scary smart and
Rich how do you feel about being an
adult and going to Disneyland I like it
you know what recently I used to go all
the time and my early 20s and I went
recently for like Valentine's Day last
year or this early so sweet and I was
like I'm over it dude that's fair I'm
officially over Disneyland they had
Epcot here I would go every [__] week
Disney World really is a different Beast
what's Epcot you walk walk around the
world or whatever the [__] it is and
they have all the different Cuisine and
beers and [__] from
all so sick same with the even the other
ones it's like a big circle yeah it's
the glob there like Magic Kingdom
there's like the animal kingdom bro I
went to the animal King this like 2018
basically a giant adult Zoo dude it's
[__] sick lowy I went to the
Cleveland Zoo I had so were you doing in
Cleveland we went to the Cleveland
Clinic just kicking it over there what
youing looking at caged animals but
honestly the zoo was tight bro we didn't
go we didn't go Rock and Roll Hall of
fame's kind of tight too have you guys
been through [__] Area 15 though yes
I love it that that all the time I love
it 15 okay man it's by meow wolf it's a
art crew it's all right it's a art crew
and they created a whole experience and
I don't want to ruin it for you you just
got to go to oh it's the [__] lights
right you can't even describe it you
have to go to Omega Mar you ever watch
Batman Forever yeah yeah it's like
thaton everywhere it's like that you
tell me about story you get to be in a
story my buddy told me he did mushrooms
there oh dude that's probably a blast he
said it was a good time imagine opening
a freezer door walking into the freezer
and going into another tunnel some on
for our Vegas trip when we go we're
going to go to Area 15 do you like
stranger things yeah you're going to
love this thing okay mhm dude not if
it's scary though you know my neon tiger
suit yeah I glow like a [__] I glow in
the dark do you like see if you walk in
there naked you probably glow in the I I
kind of do do you like Easter egg hunts
I like all of it oh you're going to
[__] love this then because you're in
a story it's
[Music]
sweet
for